hey there folks welcome to GameSpot's
the lobby our weekly chat show 2 p.m.
pacific every week we talked about games
games related topics and also video
games I'm your host Chris waters the
regular cat Danny OD is on some travels
mystery travels to Europe the continent
can we describe where he's already said
that he's gone to pull it he's in full
out loud yeah he's in Poland so if y'all
are up on the Polish development scene
which you really should be you might
know what he's seeing ah before we get
into the reason that kevin van ORD and
Eric Tay are joining me here I gotta
tell you guys something we're giving
away a headset check it out cloud to 7.1
surround sound headset we're giving it
away today to one of our lucky viewers
who's watching this live so go ahead and
reply to gamespot on twitter tell us
you're watching and that you want this
bad boy and you could win it these are
really comfy come with like a couple
different cups your ears it's nice I
couldn't need I take your word for it so
sounds like you got experience oh yeah
kinda like here for ya you might need
that later great great no no just I know
yet so I need someone set a new headset
I have like four but they always seem to
break or something goes wrong that's
because you are a monster Kevin I am a
behemoth it's true Denver Nord this week
blood-borne is out the review has like
six thousand comments or something
ridiculous right now obviously oh yes
they are popping off in those comments
and this is our ass the reviewer segment
where we talk to you about the
blood-borne review we've got questions
eric k you have also beaten blood-borne
i did last night yeah congratulation
thank you youtube blood-borne champions
first off let's just go right for the
sort of the name blood-borne doesn't say
souls in it but it's a Souls game is
this just like Dark Souls 3 with guns
hmm you could make that argument but I
would argue that no it's actually its
own what Roman would you make Kevin um
well i mean first of all the setting
it's impossible to escape that setting
and
change in setting because the souls
games have been set in like medieval
dark fantasy land and now we've got more
of it starts off with sort of a
Victorian London vibe you know Allah the
order 1886 or something like that so
it's like a much more like human
environment like more or more hat hat
more recently habit inhabited yeah it's
still inhabited for that matter and
that's that's another one of the
interesting things there are live
residents in this place and you can talk
to them through the windows and and
things like that though they never can
go outside right well it's a today it's
the night of the hunt it's an endless
night and and you're responsible for for
bringing peace and allowing them out of
their their habitats they want the
church they're there they're expecting
the church to to save the world all
right so one one of the ways that
blood-borne distinguishes itself you
know is sort of certainly in the setting
but also the story story in the souls
series has always been this very sort of
they just kind of painted on the walls
and like there's an like in the item
descriptions it's very a noncorporeal I
don't know it's something I have to like
play a lot and sort of build your own
idea of is there any like a plot or
character or story to grab onto a little
bit more here in in blood-borne yes Eric
I mean like I don't want to I don't want
to dominate the conversation fine like I
feel like actually you probably would be
better to talk about the story only
because I found myself the way I play
games is how I got lost in this game was
because I didn't hate close enough
attention to the story but i will say
you know lost in the game like
disoriented didn't know where you're
running gonna go not like totally
immersed in lost track of the president
of both a little bit of both I mean I I
I was so elated from being the boss I
didn't pay full attention to like a
cinematic or something after that kind
of gives you hints about what the story
is doing and like where you should go
next or who you might see next and those
kind of little subtle dings the thing is
I didn't play either Dark Souls but from
what I hear like the story might not
have been like the big
this deal from like I don't know that
this is just hearsay from the people
that we're watching behind me but it
seems like blood-borne kind of has a
story you're going to figure it all out
by the end and you know there's twists
and there's craziness but I don't want
to do spoilers or anything yeah I mean
blood-borne is hardly like most modern
games or any RPG really when it comes to
storytelling it's still fairly you know
it doesn't dump a lot of dialogue on you
it's still not loading you up with
cutscenes there's you know you're not
talking to a bunch of people and getting
missions that kind of thing but in
comparison with the souls games it's
it's veritably rich with story most of
it coming from environmental cues and
things like that and a lot of it you
know just through sort of the arc that
you take and I'm trying very hard not to
give anything away here we appreciate
our I'm not going to spoil anything but
there as you go through the world you
start kind of suspecting something and
then it really goes there like there's
it's not really subtle in that sense it
has something to say and it's going to
this certain place and when you first
get wind of it you're like wait is this
really what this game is doing and then
it's like oh yeah this game is not only
doing that but it's really going for it
so you know and in the past I just
thought of the souls stories is like a
sort of a tapestry that you could pay
attention to if you wanted to but it's
sort of more therefore atmosphere than
anything else that's sort of how I took
it's all right I more or less kind of
understood them over over time but I
didn't really go for that this on the
other hands like I really want people to
hurry up and finish the damn game so I
can talk about the story with them all
right let's talk about difficulty that
is something that it ended about all the
time when you talk about a Souls game a
blood-borne game so let's talk about it
first I want to ask you Eric because
here I've not played a solo game before
so just sort of generally speaking on
the spectrum of video game difficulty
how hard is this game what kind of like
diligence and perseverance do you need
to stick with it I mean it is always
relative to the player of course but you
know
average gamer it might be a little bit
harder than your normal game first of
all it doesn't really hold your hand
right so it doesn't tell you go this way
go that way you have to figure that out
yourself you are going to die a decent
amount just learning the game mechanics
you know the dodge mechanics trying to
time them properly and that's okay you
have to be okay with that like you have
to come to terms with that like that's
like almost like the first step just
knowing that you are going to die you
might lose your blood echoes why not
it's okay yeah sailing a bunch you're
not actually failing that's okay to keep
exactly and if you persevere long enough
you'll realize that the game is going to
work out like you're going to find
potential shortcuts like things that you
think are frustrating at first will kind
of sort themselves out and the game does
evolve and it gets harder but it's just
like teaching you new things and whatnot
and and growing upon the experiences
that you've gained through playing the
game so I mean it is going to frustrate
some people more than others obviously
but I would just say persevere I found
it really fun and like sometimes like I
wanted to pull my hair out but when you
beat the boss when you beat the boss and
you finally beat the boss you feel so
good because you know some of them are
really epic fights and you're just like
oh thank god i finally killed them Andy
ball gave me many bosses Kevin let's
place it on a spectrum within the its
predecessors it's for spiritual
predecessors our souls games sir is love
born the hardest of the bunch yet no no
no I would say that it's definitely not
the hardest the bunch I mean I mean I
would say that on the hierarchy um I
mean I'm sort of torn on whether demon's
souls or dark souls is actually harder
okay I think they're both tough you know
i would say probably demon's souls is
probably a little harder than dark souls
all right um but then i would say dark
souls 2 is definitely not as hard as
dark souls okay and blood-borne nozzles
currently at the top men with one horse
for me was a little bit harder than dark
souls 2 love it or not as hard as dark
souls so I would say the hierarchy
messing up from so the higher here's how
I see the higher on me on it down from
the most the the TARDIS to the least
hard demon souls dark souls blood-borne
dark souls 2
alright so in terms of sir I have a
quick question for you haven't I guess
because it was I got engaged in this
Twitter conversation with like Arthur
geese and Brad shoemaker about how they
felt that you know if you had played a
Souls game before like you know one or
two tried your hand at it you know if
you didn't think you liked it you
probably wouldn't like like blood-borne
do you feel that way Kevin because I
don't personally but that's kind of how
they felt I think it sort of depends on
what you didn't like right i mean on one
hand okay so let's say that you didn't
like the overall structure like you
don't like having to like run to get to
the boss because there's not a save
point right there or you know this
game's not changing that really or that
you don't like the overall feel of the
combat again this isn't really going to
change that for you it's sort of built
on the same structure built on the same
engine you know that kind of thing so so
a lot like a lot of the basics are still
there the fundamentals you know sort of
sit down at the bottom of things buoying
everything else up but on the other hand
let's say you didn't like it because you
didn't feel it was mobile enough or you
felt like you you know this is pretty
mobile when I'm looking at on the screen
mobile you mean like watch me die at the
end of this like nimble like it was you
know what two dies or two plotting yes
if um in a few if you really wanted
things to be mobile like this this helps
that along um you know you've and
enemies don't just stand in the same
place like like a lot of like there are
mobile enemies and dark souls and demon
souls but for the most part they just
kind of stand around waiting for you to
trigger their AI and then when that
happens then you engage in this enemies
have some behaviors they patrol um no
Suh maybe further than you expect right
so the repetition is still there and if
that's something that you didn't like if
you were just basically against the
entire idea of try and try again until
you get it right or you're powerful
enough to succeed there's no real
difference here um but the you know the
difference comes in the fact that it's
not exactly the same every time in the
sense that you know this
Ted of enemies might be in a different
place because your timing a little
differently or something all right now
so I mean I would say it's more
accessible in the sense that it's got a
story you can kind of better understand
it's maybe got a world that you can
better relate to but yeah you still have
to kind of forget what you know about
other games coming into this and learn a
new way of thinking and a new set of
rules all right speaking of the world
just a real quick one it looks like
really gray and black a lot when I look
at footage of it sometimes you guys feel
that way playing it like it is it's dark
Hall arystar sure but it's not like in
there is ever changing but there's
there's a thing that happens okay and I
tried to avoid footage doesn't get
footage so I get too far into there but
there are things that happen the world
does change okay and you know then you
might see some of the things you're
looking for does the changing help
alleviate one of the main issues that
you mention in your review and that
people have been mentioning in the
comments the loading times no and the
sort of frame rate new I mean the fray
my troubles aren't nearly on on Dark
Souls level like blight town and dark
souls was I actually I was very proud of
something I wrote in a review actually
there is a blight on this town hopefully
somebody picked up on that but they are
right i was really subtle get back in
that good anyway it's not the framerate
stuff not so bad occasionally especially
when you play co-op um you know that can
kind of take a little bit of a hit when
there's a lot going on the load times
though devs have come out I think
instead that they're looking into the
load time there was our match yeah they
are kind of long right now I wanna
venture to say it's like 30 to 40
seconds every time you die every time
you are traveling to hub world over I
think I don't know I feel like the
hunter's dream is not that bad a little
but it's because there's not a blow to
the lower e but hunters dream the hub
world to the main world that's like a 30
to 40 seconds okay like every time so if
I Cecily factor almost you some
meditative breathing enabling can use
the bathroom get some coffee get a drink
time ago
another made what born you got em
jumping down through all of these tests
with remarkable speed 30 to 40 I i will
say i don't think it would have been a
big deal dark souls 2 0 and dark souls 1
you could do this once you've got a
certain item and dark souls 2 you could
just do this from the beginning which is
like move from bonfire to bonfire i
think that that would have liked that
kind of system when if you could move
from lamp to lamp rather than having to
go all the way back to the hub and then
choose where you want to go which is the
same thing there's just two steps
instead of one right like they could
have alleviated that by not making me
have to deal with two loading screens
every time i wanted to go to a different
area they could have just you know let
me go from one lamb to the other but
that's that's sort of like a
contributing factor like maybe i
wouldn't care about the loading time so
much if you put in like this little
thing that could have you know mitigated
the issue so wait for the patch or get
blood-borne now it's a 9 out of 10 get
it now yeah now now for sure because
it's like even drunk Arlo brought
something up right now is when
everyone's experimenting and now is when
everyone's going to have like the most
excitement and the most kind of talking
to each other about this is how I'm
doing it this is how I'm doing it and
then you kind of get to bounce off ideas
instead of like a month later it's like
this is the de facto you need to do this
yeah everybody will figure out like
where you go to get to the secret area
and the the optional bosses and blah
blah blah this is the fun time when you
get to kind of discover that later on
everybody's going to know there will be
guides everywhere and whatever so you
know do it now alright populations
really high you can co-op you can PvP
the population is high in blood-borne
kevin van noord eric t thank you so much
for coming on talking about that game
folks be sure to read Kevin's review and
watch it on gamespot and also if you're
looking to get started we've got a bunch
of tip videos and just quick little
guides on waste of maneuver and
blood-borne for best success murder
times up on the site that's a technical
term right best success murder times
sounds good we do that her trailer that
right about as sophisticated as your
opening Christie yeah well I must affix
indicating a guy Kevin obviously and
coming up votes we're going to be
talking about remasters why there are so
many like there
are really a lot these days why there's
so many are they good are they bad we'll
be talking about that in just a second
but first we're gonna I don't know
there's a trailer for something probably
all right
the light binder a wise and Noble
warrior who regards life as a precious
gift mastering the power of light they
protect their allies shielding them from
enemy attacks but their kindness is not
without limit directing their powers
against an enemy a light binder is
capable of inflicting massive damage at
a significant distance the light finders
presence can shoot the outcome of an
entire battle using the ability hey they
can protect entire groups from damage or
they can elect to surround an ally with
unstable shield negating incoming damage
before detonating in a flash of light
with blessing of kinetic a light finder
can dispel harmful effects test on
allies burning tree produces a white
hawk team here to all
I star storm strikes targets with all
the compressed energy wrath of the Sun
takes down any foe who ventures too
close
finishes off weakened opponents by and
go in them in life
tough battle the light fighter can
transform into a to embodiment of life
empowering nearby allies to inflict more
damage and take less in turn this class
is perfect for those who enjoy playing
support classes and prefer to control
the battlefield if an ally all the light
binder can use an enigma of revival to
resurrect them returning them to the
fight use light energy to dictate your
own terms in back
borderlands the handsome collection
hallo master chief edition Grim Fandango
remastered Resident Evil remastered the
have a lot more written down here but
there's a lot of remasters lately what's
the deal with that joining me on the
couch to talk about that alexa ray korea
Peter Brown and Justin hey old hello all
my name some other remasters that I
missed fantasy type-0 may cry for don't
look okay good resident evil HD do we
say that I totally said that one but it
was not the right title anyways I well
you're saying a lot of remasters that
serve different purposes like summary
masters are like grim fandango is
something we hadn't seen in years like
decades like that was something that
this is the first time that so many
people got a chance to even experience
this game whereas some games like Grand
Theft Auto is technically a remaster of
the 360 ps3 game but that thing you know
that came out like last year so what
purposes does a remaster sir you name
one resurrecting a game that's you know
from way far back but they're not what
all of them do or like type 0 has never
been released in north america so HD was
its first North American do reaching new
audiences be it in new regions or on new
consoles what else we got finally you
take a game it came out for a system
where developers are constantly pushing
the system to the limits on the next
generation of consoles you have a
remastered they can finally take off
some of those shackles the game will
perform better and look better and maybe
play better too and we see a big
difference between summary masters that
that really go all out like that just
completely well in some ways redefine
the world or approach in ways that were
impossible on previous hardware and then
you also have summary masters where
minimal amount of work is done or or
really releases I guess I you wouldn't
call that a remaster earthbound is
something that comes to mind which you
know hadn't been released in a long time
was put out on the Virtual Console after
a long absence nothing additional is
added like it is just literally here's
the game on Nintendo's Virtual Console
you know a platform that lets you
experience these older games in re
release form so the reason we're talking
remasters is I mean Borderlands is out
now that includes a game that was the
pre-sequel came out in October but it
was actually only available for 360 ps3
now it's on
xbox one ps4 but god of war 3 going to
be remastered for the ps4 Batman Arkham
Asylum and Arkham City slated to rumored
to be coming out by Christmas this year
with Arkham Knight coming out in the
middle of this year now this is an
interesting one because you're kind of
like what what does a remaster what
purposes remaster serve and what risks
does it run when you're working on the
remaster of the game and a new edition
of the of that in that series at the
same time well a remaster can introduce
a set like Justin was saying a
generation of gamers that hadn't been
exposed to it before like grim fandango
and we're getting data tentacle soon
same thing with the Metal Gear
collection that came out I think last
year where it was all of them together
and that's great but some of them like
you mentioned the borderlands handsome
collection and I think that's a cash
grab because the pre-sequel came out
last year for previous gen and then
we're using it Google what six months
later less than six MOS letter for
current-gen and that to me feels kind of
like shameless and gross like why didn't
you just come out with it then yeah well
let's be honest right like publishers
have demands when it comes to shipping a
game perhaps those versions weren't
ready I think it's also fair to say that
not everyone plays every game that comes
out all the time sometimes we miss those
games and such when you have a
generational shift for consoles a lot of
people put those old systems away if
they wanted to get into a game from the
past they have the option to do that on
the current hardware versus the old one
so I don't I mean yeah it's a cash grab
because these games are money right
that's my publishers fun games and
release them and I don't know that it's
necessarily a bad thing I think it's
kind of giving people more options when
it comes to the console of choice
exactly I cash-grab isn't necessarily a
negative innocence like this is
something that it's helping fund these
publishers like that they're getting new
life in games they spent years
developing and if you want more games of
that series that both shows the
developer that you still care about this
franchise or that you're still willing
to give it a chance and then then we can
get a sequel because while they have an
influx of money and they have the
support of the fans who maybe didn't try
it before maybe just want to experience
it again right before that new iteration
that new version of it comes out and in
terms of the resources devoted to ya a
remaster versus an entirely new game
you're talking about a whole different
scale
operation very different cuz they're not
redesigning the game I mean for the most
part what they are doing are taking old
textures and updating them perhaps
having an engineer go in there and
update some of the the filters not the
filters but the stuff behind the
rendering tech right so that'll apply
anti-aliasing upscale those those a you
know the rendering frame buffer and
stuff so that could be a small team and
if it takes that small team to make that
much more money to like he's saying
support the future of a series or a
publisher I think that's a positive
thing if that's an option that people
are willing to support of course that
depends on if the remaster all goes well
and is developed and if you launch this
properly of course halo the master chief
collection had its online blows and
we've seen other remasters that they aim
is to improve technical prowess but
maybe it doesn't quite hit the mark
although you know and sometimes we want
more like I think one of the more recent
examples of a remaster or an HD remake
that disappointed too many people is
final fantasy 7 like it's you know again
we've wanted for so long and then
they're announcing your spine of fantasy
7 HD and you keep waiting for those
graphics to change to something that
looks modern and it never does and like
oh it's it's a pc version that's
slightly better looking well the amount
of money that they would have to spend
to lane and the resources that would go
into completely remaking that is just
that's any game that you you mean the
resources they'd have to spend to make
any game for modern consoles anyway it
doesn't matter that is that is the
remaking of final fantasy 7 if they're
gonna make any game that's new and
exciting it's going to be as ambitious
if not more ambitious than that game was
nearly 20 years ago I don't know I think
don't worry master thing is getting out
of hand like I think publishers need to
trust that if they have someone out
there who wants to play final fantasy 7
until the end of days that they'll keep
the hardware for it I know I do that I
though you guys do that well well going
back to I think a point of Chris made
I'm actually really excited about some
upcoming remasters because there are so
many games that especially because of
our job I just didn't have time to play
or they were on generations they like oh
that kind of passed me by Gears of War
is not something that's announced I I
assume like that has to be happening
that's there's been so many rumors for
so long and I actually kind of want that
I never played the Gears of War series
and playing it on you know a next-gen
console sounds pretty fun like I can't
imagine that would be bad master chief
collection is another 1i
is so many of those Halo games I'm
looking forward to just playing through
the entire series on a current-gen
system I don't have to keep my older
systems plugged in it's easier to access
and I know it looks better i know it's
supported that it's gonna look right i
mean some of them have problems when
they come out like master chief
collection but given enough time and in
the support of the fans who are behind
it like those versions get to be better
like they can replace that in my in my
library so i don't have to have all
these machines plugged in and again you
know having those old machines plugged
in you know you can get a copy of the
game cheap and maybe play the older
version of it but you need the older
machines plugin there was a time in this
industry that backwards compatibility
was a thing it was like a brief shining
moment and gone forever more it seems
you guys like remasters and backwards
compatibility but you know did you think
you saw that as sort of like we're not
making extra money off the backwards
compatibility yeah here's ways we can I
don't see like that I mean that's got
that's got way more to do with a
hardware code base issue than them
saying let's not do that way let's do it
this way let's hold on to it and charge
they would have to write so many
different tools to take the language for
one system to port it to another in the
case of going from powerpc-based
architecture of xbox 360 and ps3 to do
now x6 architecture of these new
consoles it it's simply not financially
feasible at that point I mean you look
at the solution for the original ps3 to
get ps2 compatibility was to literally
put a ps2 architecture inside exactly
station 3 it's like that you're not
making enough money for it and enough
people aren't using it to make that
worthwhile whereas emulation or things
like PlayStation now services like the
Virtual Console that give you access to
that back library allow the developer to
make some money off of it without you
know losing all of that to use games but
still allow you to experience those
games in a way that for me it doesn't
clutter up my living room do you guys
think a remaster could ever be
detrimental to a series I don't I mean
if it's bad it's bad it depends if
they're marketing it as something you
know completely redone and polished and
then you get something that's super
janky like master chief collection or I
know in Borderlands 2 handsome
collection the priests equals incredibly
janky to look
oh yeah so the friends like especially
when I get four players playing that the
framerate can definitely suffer because
you could sour goodwill yeah it seems
that not rare but especially with the
master chief collection like I
definitely recognize where everyone was
so hyped and then felt so burned in some
of it also comes down to do these games
hold up like nostalgia is such a
powerful thing like grim fandango is is
a game that I loved growing up and like
I don't know if I want to to try this
again and it definitely was harder going
back I mean it's beautiful and the
writing is still amazing but there's a
lot that did not age well about that
game but really long animations the
traveling back and forth across the
stage like those things don't hold up
well in modern game design even even
though the overall structure is great
and so it's like this gives you a chance
to go back and play these games but
sometimes taking the extra time to to
really remaster it instead of just kind
of rerelease it can give you a better
experience that nostalgia will tell you
was there absolutely alright let's end
on a positive note tell me some of your
favorite remasters that you have either
played or are looking forward to easy
shadow of the colossus shadow of the
colossus yeah it's a beautiful game and
just going it going from 480p to ten or
I don't know fat 720 or 1080 doesn't
matter a game was beautiful and it came
out and was made even more beautiful by
being remastered mm-hmm on the
PlayStation 3 with the team ico
collection yes The Last of Us remastered
was well I mean it was a wonderful game
to begin with it was wonderful
revisiting again but I would still be I
was like a year personal came out it's
called us I have a really short memory
grand theft auto 5 is well as mask oh oh
no that is my favorite or his mask
Majora's not very good to play that
again after so many years I was when I
was so scared wasn't gonna live up to my
expectations because I that was my
favorite Zelda game what I did it was so
well done all right any remaster
announcement predictions for this year
uncharted collection on charter
collection is yeah we're going to get a
Tartar collection we're probably going
to get what are the big things is here
that are coming out good uncharted
collaboration here's a guitarist let's
look to console games are also on PC
because then there's a really good
chance they're going to work with the
architecture
new consoles which are pretty similar
for the most part mm-hmm I'm hoping for
Milla gear rising revengeance is that
kind of pc release that came with that
yeah yeah and like if they can get that
at 1080p 60 frames per second I think in
the very near future is a good chance
we're going to see blood-borne HD for
the ola xbox one and pc you heard it
rumored here first votes all right thank
you guys for coming on chat and
remasters there sure are a lot of them
and they are intriguing all right we've
got a quick trailer for dragon age
inquisition dlc and then it's back to
the couch for an interview with greg
johnson creator of toejam and earl and
current head of human nature studios
who's running a new Kickstarter for new
entry in the cult classic series 800
years ago the last Inquisitor hunted a
great dragon
our search to find him as led us here
we've encountered hostile a bar to the
north they call themselves the jaws of
Haqq on
ages ago the old jaws of harkins of the
same they brought their God to life to
destroy the loners now they would free
him beginner
legend speaks of the last Inquisitor
before to save our lands from your God
time for me to do this thing
because
the cold wind up
is basically devastation across all a
unless we stop it now hey folks Chris
waters here to honor to hey there folks
Chris waters here honor to welcome Greg
Johnson to the set developer creator of
toejam and earl Greg thank you for
joining us all right hello here Justin
hey Walt hanging out to chat about
toejam & roll back in the groove but
this is the game you guys currently have
a Kickstarter trying to bring TGT J&E
back that's right Pharaoh we're trying
what you're trying you've got a couple
more games left your about twenty
thousand dollars short and one so is
this a new game is over good for people
that maybe haven't heard of toe gemma
neural is or this person the game you're
doing this is a completely new adventure
are you remaking the old game what is
this it is a new game but it's very
strongly based on the original game game
one pointing in elements from game 2 and
game 3 the whole idea behind it is sort
of nostalgia blast for for all the TG
any fans that have been asking for it
for so many years yes so that nostalgia
let's just do a quick little development
history here so general came out in 1991
the Sega Genesis uh it you know that it
sort of attained this cult status it
wasn't like the number one selling game
for months and months on end but it had
this real big momentum and sort of
really caught hold with folks yeah it
actually didn't do very well at first
yeah it was a very slow growth in fact
sago was looking at it initially and
thought it might be a failure mm-hmm
which is why you probably heard the
story right why they asked us to kind of
shift gears after maybe three months or
so and why we ended up going at right
angles and doing a side-scrolling
platformer instead sure so for the first
game it was sort of you know you're
exploring this this these big layered
worlds cooperatively but then the second
game you guys were working on a sequel
and then the publisher called you up and
said actually what like side scrolling
platformers are really hot right now can
you please make that happen that's right
well that's kind of pretty much what's
the mainstay of the games they did in
those days you probably remember right
that's that was the the thing they knew
how to sell and they figured that it
doing well because it wasn't that may
said can you can you give us a game with
bigger characters and more action and we
thought and still make it toejam and
earl okay i just try we'll try and then
the same thing happened you guys a
decade later working on toe general 3
for the xbox it was again harking back
to the original format but at that point
it wasn't 2d platformers that were the
hot business it was 3d yeah that's right
that was right around year 2000 when we
started in on that and that's when a 3d
right with all blocky and clunky and the
Xbox head was just coming out and
dreamcast of course is what we started
making it on and it was 3d was just
starting to look good and so that's what
we went for and and we we did start out
to make a remake of Game one that was
the plan and you know stacked levels and
all of the same stuff that was in game
one and then we got about what
three-quarters of the way through we
make quarters yeah we were mostly done
right we even had it on the Dreamcast so
you could play online multiplayer and we
had all kinds of great stuff in there
the Dreamcast was a great machine to I
really love that version of the game but
yeah then a Sega got kind of nervous and
was started getting worried that it
wouldn't appeal to new people and it was
too old school so they asked us to get
rid of the stacked levels which is kind
of why you know it's random right so you
you you you replay the game each time
you play it's different the layouts are
all directed and you die right that was
another old school thing they asked us
to change was like the permit that thing
where you die and then you start the
game over again they said no no people
don't do that anymore permadeath is not
going to be popular again for another
seven to nine year yeah so they said we
want bosses we want collectibles and we
want minigames and cinematic sequences
gates and keys slashing back to like
every bit
Joe Kazooie clone to ever yeah that
whole operation yeah well it was an era
right do you feel justified I mean
especially now seeing so many not
necessarily remakes but games that
borrow from the the sensibilities of
older games I things that come to mind
immediately like shovel Knight when
taking those old platform games axiom
verge which is super metroid that do you
feel justified that like this is
actually the kind of thing that people
want well I'm encouraged my favorite org
has um I you know I don't blame Sega for
their decision at the time I in fact we
went along with it thinking well okay
you guys know better than we do and we
want to make a game that's successful
and if you really think that's what this
needs to be and it's your money on the
line okay right it was it was hard you
know but but now yeah it is nice to see
all that old stuff kind of coming back
again all those mechanics and I'm
feeling like oh all right well maybe um
maybe we can really go back old school
and um but I still wasn't sure you know
I shopped this around to publishers over
the years and in and Mark poor thing or
two you know he was the original creator
with me but he kind of got out of the
game business maybe seven or eight years
ago good but yeah they they they didn't
bite and said none of the properties too
old we don't think there's enough of a
demand so I i I've been getting emails
so constantly and then you guys are
probably very aware of the whole retro
movement right and always nostalgia
that's just been growing and growing
over the last four or five years mhm so
I've been getting this increasing demand
and now with Kickstarter I thought well
let's see this will be a chance to
really test the waters and see if that
old school stuff is still still what
people want and we've seen some success
with things like wasteland just I mean
feeding off of people's nostalgia for
those games that I mean aren't changed
it it always is the same formula the
same kind of art style that these are
things that at least a group of people
want but publishers aren't as willing to
put money behind it even though there is
a demand
yeah right it is it's understandably
risky i guess but that's the wonderful
thing about going india and and things
like Kickstarter or you go go so we can
just give it a shot and see what happens
and you even get to test the waters
before you spend all that money and
build the game so i think that's pretty
cool it seems like the independent indie
game development is something that may
be over the past ten years has become
much more sort of part of the mainstream
discussion of video games in general but
you've kind of been doing an independent
game developer thing for a couple
decades very decade yeah you basically
lived the like horrible specter of any
developer publisher relationship right
that you'd be doing your thing and then
they'd come in and say not your thing
our thing and you just say but okay so
but you're it but then again you for
making a tea genie back in the groove
you wanted to shop around the publishers
and stuff like that so i guess how is
your sort of perspective on working with
publishers evolved or remain sort of the
right perspective to keep you sort of
optimistic about that well like anything
there's upsides and downsides you know
challenges in any direction you go so
I'm not a real big believer I maybe I
used to be in the grass is greener of
you it's just doesn't work out that way
so you know I just had a really great
publisher experience recently with Sony
doing doki-doki universe yeah but youíve
you know that game right you do and
interviewed me about that really pretty
bizarre and that yeah that game is not
what I would say a publisher would look
at and be like oh yeah this one's this
one's going off the shelves no problem
exactly right yeah they were willing to
take a risk and they were very hands-off
and just said go for it and I were even
times when I was like is it okay to put
a talking toilet or put you on a flying
poo and you know all this weird stuff
and they're like sure go before game so
so yeah so they're not publishers aren't
evil in fact you know I I kind of feel
like I've seen transition you know like
you said I'm
guy he didn't quite say that I mean I'm
diplomatic here oh yeah but um you know
since 1981 when I started in the
business and EA was like 30 people I was
my first game with Starflight right and
and I've seen the industry change and
grow over the years and um publishers
have gotten a lot nicer I think really
you know they still their legal
departments are still aggressive Shonda
and they're very very risk-averse
especially as the number of dollars that
they spend go up they get more and more
risk-averse but um I think because the
game industry has matured and people
have now been in the industry for much
longer there's a likes meet people you
know person after person in various
publishers who have been doing it for a
long time and want to make stuff that's
meaningful and and just I'm out I'm
always surprised at that I shouldn't
because I feels like in the old days it
was a harsher world in dealing with
publishers do you think it's because
both publishers people working there
getting older and the the audience like
we are older gamers there then when we
were all sorting out I think so i think
also um it may be because in the last
what I don't know 52 even maybe even 10
years maybe more like five to eight
years the whole indie movement has grown
up and you know with first digital games
you know being downloaded and then
mobile games and now sort of with
crowdsource funding there's been just
this increasing awareness of indie games
and sort of innovation and I think
there's a growing appreciation for that
I know sony has certainly embraced that
and I was talking someone recently who
was telling me that Microsoft is kind of
you know wanting to move in that
direction too yeah they've got a whole
ID ate at a detox program that sort of
mirrors Sony's own recent push into sort
of indie development yeah so would you
say like indie developers like now's the
time maybe you know maybe one EA was 30
people like you maybe get
up there but now is a better time to
sort of be an independent developer yeah
that's a tough one it's a very mixed bag
yeah because there's a lot more
opportunities out there now and you can
just you can make it gained much cheaper
with the tools available and you can get
money from directly from you know like
crowdsource funding but because it's
easier there's a lot of competition too
yeah so um but it's definitely the path
Ian I get asked a lot you know by a lot
of young people how can I get started in
the industry and you know as opposed to
sort of taking the QA route or taking a
real low-level job at a publisher and
working your way up or even getting a
job at a big developer house I I usually
say if you can do it build a game
yourself first download unities start
working yeah right and just it just
shows so much initiative and sort of
it's a way to get you know get some
attention yeah all right so Kickstarter
is winding down you've been added about
a month with a toe jam and rolled back
in the groove yes I just a few days away
from wrapping up what has been your what
sort of been an early or I guess later
take away from running a kickstarter
campaign for you know trying to try to
bring us back oh my gosh i mean i'm sure
we can do an entire other interview away
i give me one or two like top level like
it would you do it on would you go back
to kickstarter yeah you know it's funny
um this is i don't know how
inappropriate this metaphor may or may
not be but it's kind of like having a
baby you know it's sort of like you
don't ask a woman if she'll have another
baby right before the baby's born you
gotta wait a month or two because it's
intense you know I have a lot of friends
in the industry you know and I'm lucky
that way because I've been around a long
time Tim Schafer is one person who's
clearly you know been around the block
as far as Kickstarter goes and so I've
been getting a lot of advice and I was
warned but um man I I kind of should lie
down on this couch because I think I
might start a support group for people
that do Kickstarter's
so it's intense key takeaway lots of
screaming quite a bit of blood yeah well
a metaphor doesn't go that far Yeah Yeah
right I gotta shift gears now and
changed my mental image it's it's
intense but a lot of that intensity is
really good intensity is just a lot you
know so it's sort of like you open the
floodgates and now and all of a sudden
you're talking to two thousand people at
once and everybody is valid you know you
want to listen to everybody yes they're
the people you're building for and you
care about and at the same time you're
doing that you're trying to you know
write articles and do podcasts and
figure out how you're going to get toys
manufactured in China and your
fulfillment center you know where you're
going to get that sent to and everybody
wants to know do you make shirt sizes in
you know 4xl and and you know just
everything but game developments it is
it's crazy it's like a sprint you know
for a month I was going to say marathon
but you kind of run slow a marathon a
much faster pace yeah but there's some
great resources out there now that have
grown up like some infrastructure so
we're working with this company in Texas
called amplifier and they do
manufacturing and fulfillment and
customer service and I ship everything
out and we're working with this other
great company called backer kit and they
collect all of the data from oh you've
heard of them you're nodding no I I back
way too many things very avid
Kickstarter oh yeah yeah it's becoming
kind of the norm now actually so I'm not
surprised I'm actually more surprised
when I hear people not doing that
because um it's just you know unless
your Kickstarter small it's just too too
hard to handle too much to handle on
your own so that may say that the
industry you know has expanded even to
those sort of companies that support
your Kickstarter campaign and stuff like
yeah isn't that funny the brave little
infrastructure out there now all right I
had one quick question yeah a lot of
developers especially any guys now they
get to design their games to be you know
purposefully retro but when I look at
toejam and earl like I I don't think
anything screams 90s more than the
design of those characters here did you
give any thought to like revamping it or
to me maybe changing it to make it more
2000s to the 15 no I'm glad you said
that actually because that's the whole
point yeah and it is I really wanted it
maybe we even went too far that's
possible I don't know but I I looked for
an artist this guy Nathan shorts that
does his whole thing is sort of retro
comics and and it's all about the you
know I grew up child of the 70s funk
funk bass and like that you know i was
in my high school we you know people
were carrying those boom boxes around
their shoulder playing low rider and
stuff and and yeah i just thought it
would be really fun for people so we
went for the you know the 2d sprites man
this is sort of comic book you look I
mean the 90s sort of Schoolhouse Rock
kind of look so um I wanted to do
something that was fresh I didn't want
to just redo the same same thing so and
that's tricky you know when you do a
sequel because people want it the same
but they also want it different in this
kind of this line you gotta walk so army
stuff yeah you need a pass but making it
fresh again yeah right Greg thanks so
much for coming on it I bet toejam and
earl back in the groove just a few days
left on kickstarter folks check it out
if you're interested thanks for watching
all right and that'll do for our show
today I hope hopefully one of you guys
won the headsets we're going to be
announcing that on Twitter a little bit
later Greg thank you again so much for
coming in and go any time by the game I
know that you're you know counting down
the days and it's the ever getting close
yeah I know almost there almost there oh
yeah again no pest of luck to you and
Justin thank you so much for us thanks
for having me on much appreciated I'm
Chris waters lobby we'll be back next
week at two p.m. pacific with more games
more check and more games chat we'll see
you then
you